Marvel fans, I am
here with Marisa Tomei.
How's it going?
- Hi.
Going good.
Getting very excited for
everyone to see this movie.
It's the big-- the big opening.
The energy is amazing.
I'm so excited.
Yeah, it's-- it's very--
it's really thrilling.
So what has May been up
to since we last left off?
Well-- well, her-- her
and Peter Parker have
gone through a lot together.
They're growing up.
They've been through
several cycles
of on and off relationships
with other people.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
They're hanging out.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, that's a lot.
Uh-huh.
So everyone knows that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
How is May handling that?
I think that-- well-- well,
May was shocked at first.
And-- and then, you
know, then she found out.
And they became a team.
They just really work together.
And she's in on it with him.
And she also tries
to protect the part
of him that's still a boy
and lets him do his thing.
INTERVIEWER: I love that.
So I need you to spill
the tea, all right?
May has, kind of, a different
understanding when it comes
to her relationship with Happy.
What-- is there a
relationship there?
What's going on?
I don't-- I don't think--
I mean, there's a relationship.
There's a friendship.
And they've also--
they're, like, compadres.
They've been through
so much together.
They've been lovers.
They've been friends.
They've been on.
They've been off.
I don't know why you think
I have a different-- why?
Do you have a different
understanding?
Well, I mean, the last
movie, it was, kind of, like,
a little back and--
- Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Yes, true.
What was it like to work with
this incredible cast again?
Oh, it's just so great
to see-- to see them.
They're always doing
something new and different.
And they-- they just--
they're so beautiful.
They're beautiful to look at.
They're beautiful inside.
And it's always fun to come
back and be with them again.
Well, I'm excited to see
you on the big screen tonight.
I won't keep you
from the red carpet.
Thank you for
spending time with us.
Thanks.
Thanks to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]